ente gut alles gut oder etwa doch nicht
entengericht im Asia-Imbiss Kosten
häufig unter 10 Euro doch das geht zu
Lasten von Tierwohl und Küchentradition
da ist die Peking entenromantik auch
gleich vorbei Sebastian zeigt mit
welchem Mitteln die Industrie
Entenfleisch knusprig trägst
[Musik]
ein chinesisches Traditionsgericht super
erfolgreich kennt jeder liebt jeder
und die machen wir einfach mal Sebastian
lege zeigt erst einmal wie Peking Ente
traditionell zubereitet wird dafür
benötigt er vor allem beste Zutaten eins
darf nicht fehlen five Spice Pulver
das sogenannte fünf Gewürzpulver ist das
Markenzeichen der echten asiatischen
Küche
es besteht aus Anis Fenchel Zimt
Kardamom und Nelke
[Musik]
ist jetzt angesagt Sebastian lege
verwendet eine Ente vom lokalen
Bauernhof ernährt sie luftdicht zu
wir müssen die Haut vom Fleisch lösen
damit dieses Fett was dazwischen ist
sich gleichmäßig immer wieder im
Garprozess um das Fleisch schmiegen kann
würde das Fett aufliegen wird es nicht
funktionieren wir brauchen diesen
luftleeren Raum damit das Fett immer
wieder kontinuierlich sein Saft an das
Fleisch abgeben kann und wie löse ich
jetzt die Haut vom Fleisch ganz einfach
und Kompressor
[Musik]
traditionell setzen Köche auf einen
handblase bei Bike heute kommt
tatsächlich häufig Hochdruck aus der
Maschine zum Einsatz
[Musik]
so
die Ente bekommt im ersten Schritt ein
lauwarmes Wasserbad das öffnet die Poren
traditionelle Peking-Ente hat am Ende
eine knusprig gläsere haut
man kann jetzt schon sehen wie die Haut
sich verändert die glatt das wird
fehlt noch die Spezialbehandlung der
gebadeten Ente der Produktentwickler
sprüht eine Mischung aus Salz Essig
Wasser und Zucker auf die Haut auf
danach muss die Ente mehrere Stunden
trocknen dafür hat Sebastian lege einen
Ventilator besorgt
Pekingenten Garen in speziellen Öfen die
Ente darf nirgends auflegen sie hängt
frei so wird das Fleisch schonend gegart
und die Haut gleichmäßig knusprig
oh das Quallen das qualmt die Enten
müssen raus
die Herstellung einer original Peking
Ente kann bis zu drei Tagen dauern auch
das macht das Traditionsgericht so teuer
ist richtig krass aber auch ganz viel
Arbeit deswegen kostet das auch 1 € ist
ja auch total berechtigt aber das Zeugs
was uns mal einen schnell an die Tür
bringen lassen wo dann drauf steht mit
gebräunter Ente das ist nicht so
aufwendig gemacht wie das hier echte
Peking Ente in einem guten Asia
Restaurant ist extrem knusprig die Haut
glänzt golden und das Fleisch ist sehr
zart schon im Einkauf kostet da eine
Ente auf 30 € pro Stück günstige
Restaurants sparen am Fleisch eine
industrieente kostet nur 10 € fix und
fertig vorgegart wird sie im
Plastikbeutel verkauft das geht auf
Kosten der Tiere
Entenfleisch ist keine cash-caro also es
ist es ist allgemein so der entenmarkt
ist ein sehr
heiklermarkt für Landwirte Enten fühlen
sich überall dort wohl wo es viel Wasser
gibt in ihrer natürlichen Umgebung
werden die Wasservögel bis zu 15 Jahre
alt
für die maskenindustrie rechnet sich
eine artgerechte Aufzucht nicht
turbo-züchtung in Stellen ist die
Realität diese Bilder aus Ungarn zeigen
Teiche für die Wasservögel gibt es hier
keine
[Musik]
die entenmester in Deutschland viele
aber auch in Polen und Ungarn leben alle
an einem sehr knappen finanziellen Level
also werden eigentlich immer von den
großeinkäufern in Deutschland so halb am
Verhungern gehalten um die Preise schön
tief zu halten und wo keine großen
Gewinne zu holen sind ja ist der Bauer
halt auch nicht sehr erpicht drauf
irgendwie ja was bisschen schöner zu
machen und der Preisdruck steigt weiter
bis vor wenigen Jahren wurde
Entenfleisch für die Gastronomie auch in
Deutschland produziert der
geflügelkonzern Wiesenhof machte
Milliarden Umsätze inzwischen hat sich
der Konzern aus dem entengeschäft für
die Gastronomie zurückgezogen auf unsere
Anfrage teilt uns der Konzern mit leider
ist es uns aufgrund der anhaltenden
Kostensteigerungen sowie der
verschärften Wettbewerbssituation durch
Anbieter außerhalb Deutschlands nicht
mehr möglich zukunftsfähig und
nachhaltig zu arbeiten
[Musik]
Entenfleisch für die deutsche
Gastronomie wird zu rund 80% im Ausland
unter fragwürdigen Bedingungen
produziert
[Musik]
Turbo gemästetes Fleisch hat dadurch
nicht die gleiche Qualität und trotzdem
ist die Ente im Asia-Restaurant immer
saftig und knusprig wie da getrickst
wird zeigt Sebastian lege
gebratene Nudeln mit knuspriger Ente ist
doch gar kein Problem und das Ganze für
10 Euro
da ist die Peking entenromantik auch
gleich vorbei wir brauchen auf alle
Fälle erstmal ein Haufen Zutaten
Honig Salz Zucker Maltodextrin Glutamat
Wasser asiatische Gewürze ein Cocktail
für die günstige Zucht Ente
das einzige was an den Zutaten teuer ist
ist das Gewürzpulver aber dafür brauchen
wir auch nur ganz wenig was würde
intensiviert mit dem Glutamat ein
bisschen Pulver ein bisschen Booster
viel Geschmack
Sebastian liege hat die ganze Ente in
zwei Hälften zerteilt
los geht's so
das ist unsere ganze Ente
[Musik]
hier kommt mein Highspeed marinierer zum
Einsatz und jetzt wird mariniert
der ist doch viel einfacher und ich kann
genauer dosieren hier
schnell und sparsam perfekt für die
Industrie
[Musik]
so vor allen Dingen jetzt durch die
feine Zerstäubung geht die Marinade in
jede kleine Ritze rein und
ich habe richtig Geschwindigkeit drauf
weil Arbeitszeit kostet Geld und
das wollen wir nicht bezahlen unsere
gebratene Nudeln Ende dürfen wir nicht
mehr wie 10 € Kosten ne ja
traurig
auch beim Garen wird getrickst
Dampfgaren heißt das Zauberwort
Vorteil bei wasserdampf ist wir haben
kein Gasverlust nee weil wir pumpen ja
noch Wasser rein das heißt Gewicht vom
Rohgewicht zum Endgewicht bleibt gleich
die Ente gab im Ofen mit Knochen
verkauft wird das Fleisch fix und fertig
als Filet
und jetzt löse ich hier die Knochen
einfach aus ein mieser Job an Asiens
Fließbändern
die halbe Pekingente ohne Knochen fix
und fertig für die Fritteuse beim
asiatischen Schnellimbiss
dieser Ente ist noch weich statt
knusprig Sebastian lege weiß was da
hilft ja das passiert im jeden Asia
Bringdienst nur unter den Kulissen so
sieht er gar nicht und auch Mehl Wasser
Stärke kostet ja auch kein Geld aber
bringt Gewicht und macht schnell satt
Sebastian lege bestreicht die halbe Ente
dick mit mehl und Stärke in heißem Öl
wird daraus eine knusprige Hülle
[Musik]
was beim Original mehrere Tage dauert
erledigt die Friteuse in wenigen Minuten
[Musik]
und fertig ist unsere
Turbo Peking Ente
richtig schön knusprig ja so soll sie
schmecken
hat noch nicht viel mit dem Original zu
tun
knusprige Haut überdeckt im Zweifel auch
den Geschmack von schlechten Fleisch
[Musik]
falsche Peking Ente serviert Sebastian
lege nun auch seinen Restaurant Gästen
jo schöne Auflösung gleich hier am Tisch
es war Ente
knusperpanade hat unheimlich gut
geschmeckt also auch die die also
panadien noch den Dingen den
entengeschmack so ein bisschen
überlagert also es war super
Sebastian lege ist wichtig dass seine
Gäste in Zukunft ihr Essen anders
wahrnehmen
hier wollen wir euch zeigen dass gerade
dieses Produkt wo wir sagen wow so eine
Ente ist was besonderes gab es bei der
Mama immer nur auf dem Sonntag zum
Massenprodukt geworden ist diese Enten
werden wirklich in der Massentierhaltung
gehalten und das gerade solche Produkte
nicht wirklich dem Tierwohl entsprechen
und das ein oder andere Mal sollte man
darauf achten